herzlich willkommen hier bei bild live
wo wir heute den amerikanischen
außenminister mike p o begrüßen dürfen
im business secretary good morning to
washington dc sehr schön bei ihm zu sein
amerika hat weltweit die meisten toten
in der korona krise zu beklagen gibt es
etwas was das amerikanische volk in
dieser dramatischen krise von
deutschland erwartet was ist ihre
botschaft an kanzlerin angela merkel
schauen sie wir arbeiten sehr eng mit
unseren deutschen freunden und partnern
zusammen in dieser globalen pandemie
wir arbeiten an lösungen wie wir zum
beispiel ausrüstungsgegenstände an die
richtigen orte bringen es geht hier um
impfstoffe die wissenschaftler arbeiten
sehr stark zusammenhang allen
medizinischen maßnahmen
es ist eine globale pandemie und
deutschland ist ein großartiger partner
wir sind sehr froh angela merkels unsere
partnerin zu haben und das deutsche volk
und wir arbeiten zusammen
nicht nur für die usa und deutschland
sondern für die ganze welt
der deutsche außenminister heiko maas
hat die usa und china in einem atemzug
kritisiert hat gesagt china hätte zu
autoritär auf die korona krise reagiert
die usa hingegen hätten das problem
verharmlost macht es sie ärgerlich wenn
die diktatur china und die demokratie
usa in einem atemzug so kritisiert
werden nun die zwei genannten länder
haben ja sehr unterschiedlich reagiert
auf diese krise die usa mit us-präsident
trump hat sehr starke maßnahmen
ergriffen um unser volk zu schützen und
wir sprechen die aber ganz
unterschiedliche systeme 400 millionen
dollar sind zum beispiel von den usa zur
verfügung gestellt worden für den kampf
gegen korona ich habe schon mal gesagt
dass es uns wirklich dass wir es
wirklich sehr bedauern dass dieser virus
in buer han china ausgebrochen ist und
nicht schnell genug bekannt wurde weil
die chinesische regierungsparteien nicht
schnell genug ins information gegeben
hat das ist natürlich sehr bedauerlich
die ganze welt hat jetzt dieses problem
aber wir sprechen über zwei ganz
unterschiedliche antworten auf diese
krise ich weiß dass die amerikanische
und die deutsche regierung sehr stark
zusammenarbeiten
dieses risiko zu minimieren
die berliner regierung hat den usa sogar
piraterie vorgeworfen fälschlich
vorgeworfen weil angeblich die usa
masken konfisziert haben sollten auf dem
weg nach berlin mussten sich später
dafür entschuldigen sind sie besorgt
über diese form von antiamerikanismus in
der deutschen hauptstadt
ganz sicher wollen wir dass wir als gute
partner uns unterhalten über unsere ganz
wichtigen beziehungen unserer beiden
ländern aber um noch mal auf ihren punkt
zu kommen
wir haben das überall gesehen in den
medien gibt es so viel dass
informationen falsche informationen
viele menschen bisschen vielleicht gar
nicht dass wir falsch informationen
verbreiten
ich weiß nicht ob die leute in
deutschland so gut informiert waren so
sehr im bilde sein aber noch einmal es
gibt wirklich gefährliche diese
information egal woher sie kommen aus
dem iran zum beispiel egal woher das ist
ein echtes risiko wir brauchen wirklich
gute information wir brauchen fakten
zahlen
weg von der ideologie wir müssen
zusammenarbeiten diese krise zu lösen
und wir müssen unsere wirtschaft wieder
hinbekommen und deswegen brauchen wir
wie das land das wir jetzt alle zusammen
arbeiten mit echten informationen und
fakten in den letzten monaten wurde
immer wieder über zölle gesprochen zelle
die zum beispiel in deutschland auf
amerikanische produkte erhoben werden
wäre ist ein möglichkeit diese zölle auf
amerikanische produkte in deutschland
oder in der eu zu senken um die us
wirtschaft weiter anzukurbeln die so
wichtig für die weltwirtschaft ist ich
glaube präsident trump ist da ganz klar
in seinen äußerungen wir wollten
handelsbeschränkungen abschaffen wir
wollen keine zölle keine strafzölle
wollen freien welt wirtschafts handels
und ganz wichtig dass wir einen fairen
handel haben von beiden seiten
das streben wir an und wenn das
handelsbeschränkungen gibt dann muss
jede partei die aus der welt schaffen
egal mit welchem land wollen wir einen
fairen handel haben von beiden seiten
fair geführt deswegen arbeiten wir auch
daran dass die weltweite wirtschaft
wieder anwächst und ich hoffe sehr dass
die europäischen länder die eu
auch mitarbeiten dass wir diese
handelsbeschränkungen abschaffen und
dann wird die weltwirtschaft wieder
anspringe
sie haben es selber gesagt diese krise
hat begonnen in hahn
china braucht es eine globale debatte
darüber ob der chinesischen regierung
für die massiven schäden die weltweit
angerichtet worden sind eine rechnung
präsentiert werden muss nun wir brauchen
mehr als eine globale debatte es ist
ganz wichtig dass wir verstehen wo
dieser virus herkommt wo der ursprung
ist und wir sprechen über fakten das
sprechen über die wirtschaft nicht über
politische meinungen das ist ganz
wichtig dass wir uns darauf
konzentrieren
wir müssen herausfinden wie konnte das
passieren um sicherzustellen dass so
etwas nie wieder passiert oder wird
zumindest das risiko minimieren dass so
etwas nie wieder passiert das ist
wirklich essentiell dass wir verstehen
dieser virus herkamen und um das risiko
zu minimieren wir haben ja diese
geschichten gehört über diese seltsam
märkte in china und wir haben die bilder
gesehen wo das virus herkommt die welt
muss das wissen wir wollen die besten
wissenschaftler aus china dass wir daran
arbeiten dass wir den ursprung finden
bietet sich das weltweit ausbreiten
konnte damit wir die richtigen schritte
ergreifen können auch in hinblick auf
die weltwirtschaft es wird wirklich hohe
kosten geben
und deswegen müssen wir sicherstellen
dass kein land auf der welt wieder der
ursprung einer solchen krise sein kann
das ist ja wirklich eine krise noch
einmal soll china für diese schäden die
dort entstanden sind finanziell
aufkommen
wissen sie ich hab ihn schon gesagt dass
wir daran arbeiten das risiko zu
minimieren den nächsten tagen die
strategie fortführen unsere maßnahmen
greifen wir müssen natürlich alle
verstehen wo das herkam und alle müssen
daran mitarbeiten die dafür
verantwortlich sind dass ist eine
spätere frage jetzt im augenblick ist es
essentiell dass wir uns auf unsere
strategie auf dieses problem
konzentrieren dass die systeme wieder
arbeiten damit wir die us amerikanische
wirtschaft wieder hochfahren und auch
die weltwirtschaft wieder hochfahren ist
wird eine zeit geben wo wir uns damit
auseinandersetzen
thank you very much to washington
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen schönen tag
für sie danke